hi everyone is Charlie we only have one
week left until Game of Thrones starts
so I've got a lot of questions about my
predictions for who's gonna go during
the season there are way more than ten
but I just did this as a top ten video
so I'll add the bonus ones because there
are a couple big characters that didn't
make my list that I definitely think are
gonna die sometime during the season
we're doing weekly HBO now giveaways for
my Game of Thrones videos all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so for each
of these people I try to explain when
and how and justify why the show seems
to foreshadow or something that the
actors said that implies that they're
gonna go in some spectacular way during
the season starting with number 10 grey
worm also I think with a high
probability that he's a character that
comes back as an undead white after the
Battle of Winterfell mid-season I just
did a video for the Game of Thrones
premiere season 8 episode 1 that they
had a couple days ago
at that event Jacob Anderson the actor
that plays gray worms said that fans
would feel very conflicted about his
characters ending for the series he
didn't flat-out spoil what's gonna
happen to his character or say that he's
gonna die in battle but when he says
fans will be very conflicted about what
happens to him
Vecchi screams I'm probably gonna come
back as an undead white and even though
I wasn't the most popular character some
of the fans loved me and seeing me as a
white will traumatize them forever in
the best possible way we've all been
theorizing about which of the main
characters would come back as an undead
white most people are thinking about
Hodor because that would be the most
traumatic thing but because so many
people are at this battle of Winterfell
and there's no way that they're gonna
have time to burn all those bodies of
course some of them will probably come
back as undead whites
there are a couple different ways that
something like this could go down so
they have the Battle of Winterfell you
see him with the unsullied legions there
he dies some time during this battle
they could one either bring him back as
a white during that same episode because
the battle itself will be longer than 60
minutes he'll be crazy long episode
that's just them fighting the white
walkers but they could also choose to do
a Viserion style twist where you just
see it happen at the end of the episode
then in a much later episode you see him
as an undead white freaking everyone out
but number 9 the mountain also pretty
easy prediction to make if all the
characters made lists like Arya he would
be on several
of those lists and you have to get rid
of him in order to get to Cersei who as
you would expect is also on my list here
there was a very telling conversation
that Arya and the Hound had back during
season four by the campfire when he
yelled at her for reciting her list
telling her just to be quiet but then
sort of turned around on it and said
okay hate is as good a thing as any to
keep someone going because at that point
that was all Arya had she had thought
that she lost her entire family but then
the Hound suggests that if they were to
both find themselves in King's Landing
again in the future that they could both
cross the name off their list together
aka the mountain they come across my
brother maybe we can both cross a name
off a list so I feel like that's as much
foreshadowing as the show could ever
give you about a team-up of sorts to
slay the mountain at the end of the
season but number eight the Hound is
also on my list here because I think
part of the reason for the team-up with
Arya is necessary is because the Hound
as badass as he is won't be able to get
the mountain all by himself and will die
in the attempt like sacrificing himself
in order to help Arya finish the job
whether or not he knows that she's going
to jump in at the last moment and help
finish the job
just because the zombie Mountain is so
hard to kill so sure you could dowse
them in wildfire and just watch him burn
to a crisp but that would fly in the
face of any kind of cleganebowl matchup
and it would be a big middle finger to
the fans like haha we're not gonna give
you cooking Bo after all you start but
not all his life um he's not gonna stop
he's gonna complete on that mission
seven the undead Wight Vissarion in his
current form Daenerys is not gonna have
fun having to destroy her child again
but you could argue whether or not it's
possible to kill something that's
already dead but they'll have to destroy
vissarion to get to the night King
anyway so that's sort of like the
mountain in front of Cersei you have to
get rid of the obstacle before you can
get to the true goal so say goodbye to
Viserion again but number six another
one of Daenerys dragons her dragons are
such a huge advantage to her in battle
weapons of mass destruction is the way
that people on the show refer to them
with all the foreshadowing that we've
seen mid-season in the possible
destruction of Winterfell Daenerys and
Jon Snow's forces being decimated before
the end of the season it just feels like
they're gonna have to sacrifice another
dragon in their attempt to get rid of
Viserion in the night king but i still
do think that the series is
foreshadowing that Daenerys is going to
use
her dragons possibly drogon to destroy
the iron throne by the end of the season
so at least one of the dragons would
have to survive in order to make that
possible
but these characters are going to be
metaphorically tortured in all kinds of
ways during the season in what better
way is there for a writer to torture
Daenerys than to get rid of another one
of her children even though that sounds
kind of like a bummer getting rid of her
dragons I do think that the show will
find time to suggest or at least imply
that Drogo or Ragle could have laid some
new dragon eggs at some point so it's
not all bad laying new dragon eggs and
possible Daenerys pregnancy via John
Snow all just tie in with the themes of
a dream of spring hopefully they'll use
that as the title for the finale but
number five beric Dondarrion also
another pretty easy prediction to make
he's died and been brought back to life
by the Lord of Light and Thoris of mere
six times there will probably not be a
seventh but you could make a lot of
jokes about the faith of the seven
there's a lot of foreshadowing with
religion and the way that they're tying
everything up at the end of the series
so we'll talk about that during episode
videos when we get big Easter eggs but
right now Melisandre has said that she
would come back for the war for the dogs
so technically she would be around to
resurrect anyone if she wanted to do
that Jon Snow has already told her
please don't bring me back if I fall in
battle again but it just feels like
beric has already achieved most of the
purpose that the show needs him for one
to serve as a tutorial for Resurrection
early in the show's run foreshadowing
Jon Snow coming back to life at the
beginning of season six - to inspire the
Hound to join the Brotherhood without
banners and lead then north of the wall
it provides some clarity for what the
Hound was singing the flames with
Thoreau's of Muir in three two give Jon
Snow the explainer for how to best
defeat the army of whites all we have to
do is kill him he who created all of
these and we destroy them in an instant
he's basically giving Jon the Thanos
Thor explainer from infinity war go for
the head you should have gone for the
head there is footage of him inside the
season 8 trailer so clearly they want to
use him for some other explainer scene
where he uncovers some information then
conveys that once the show has used him
for that task he'll be free to die some
spectacular death for your on Greyjoy
also one of those easy predictions to
make he's one of those characters that
they've used is a very clear villain for
our heroes to destroy the past couple
seasons primarily Theon Greyjoy into a
lesser degree
greyjoy although pretty much all the
other characters on the show hate him
with a passion even Cersei Lannister
hates Euron even though Theon may never
truly be king of the Ironborn again
getting rid of Euron and rescuing Yara
is the final test of his Redemption arc
which started when he sacked Winterfell
given the chance Jaime other characters
would do it themselves but I feel like
most of Hurons battles this season will
be with Theon in his smaller band of
Ironborn like we see Theon ships sailing
in the trailer they seem like they're
sailing down to King's Landing to face
your on themselves 3 Jaime Lannister
also pretty easy prediction to make he
already said it himself he's going to
die in the arms of someone he loves I
will be disappointed if that person
winds up being Cersei and not Brienne of
Tarth he's on the same type of
Redemption arc that Theon is on I think
he'll be successful but after he
achieves Redemption that's when he goes
like the moment of his death is tied up
in his moment of redemption I did the
thing that I set out to do I'm not a
terrible person like everybody has been
calling me my entire life - then of
course Cersei Lannister
even though Maisie Williams has said
that Arya is a list is still very much a
thing during season eight and spent most
of that interview talking about Cersei
being at the top of her list there's a
number of people that want to get rid of
Cersei the show has never officially
endorsed the valonqar prophecy but
translated into the common tongue the
prophecy states that she would die at
the hands of the younger sibling
non-gendered because the Valyrian
language doesn't really translate that
way so it could be the younger brother
like Tyrion or Jaime Lannister or a
younger sister like Arya the prophecy is
vague enough that it could be anyone's
younger sister or brother so if you want
to hold out hope for the jackpot paying
off double that would be Arya doing it
wearing Jaime's face but I don't want to
get my hopes up too much about that
level of fanservice Cersei is the Mad
Queen though so she needs to go out in a
moment referencing the way that the Mad
King died even if it's not the exact
same way
number one on everyone's hit list of
course is the night king simple
prediction to mate there's lots of
theories about the mythology in the
twist of how he might die but the main
goal of the season beyond the battle for
the Iron Throne is the battle to get rid
of the night king unless they do this
cycle repeats and this happens all over
again in another generation and as
Daenerys said they're trying to break
the wheel break the cycle so that means
that they absolutely have to get rid of
the night king but because that's only
ten and I think there are way more big
main characters that are gonna die
during the season bonus predictions here
we go Jorah mormon all he wants to do
now is serve Daenerys in fight in battle
he doesn't really fit in when they're
sitting around talking about battle
planning and all this politicking that's
not him he feels best when he has a
sword in his hand and he's charging the
field
he's been on something of a Redemption
arc himself ever since before season 1
because remember he fled Ned Stark's
justice because he was slaving his own
people on Bear Island so there's still
some atonement that he has to serve this
season in a glorious death in battle of
defeating the White Walkers would be a
way of achieving that Tyrion Lannister
also on the list now apparently people
that saw episode 1 just dramatically
shot him up to death predictions list so
whatever it is that they want to do is
here in this season it seems like
they're gonna use his tongue to get him
in trouble bran Stark is also on the
list because he's so powerful it feels
like he gives them a decisive advantage
so it just feels like he might sacrifice
himself in their attempt to defeat the
night king Melisandre also foretold of
her death when she was talking to Varys
like she said that they were all meant
to die on this continent when she was
leaving like don't worry I'll be back
because we're destined to die in the war
for the dawn bran also shot up my
predictions list when he said that
everyone's gonna hate him this season
because of what he's doing I think that
implies that he's gonna be serving
Cersei in one way or another during the
season it just seems to imply he's going
to betray the characters that he's been
friends with before in the name of
getting his castle as he wants it so
badly
smaller prediction but you could also
put the dire wolves on this list to
ghost
Nymeria in her super pack technically
there are only two of the original dire
Wolf's left ghosts in Nigeria everybody
post your death predictions in the
comments below what will happen is
there'll be a couple more big bonus
videos during the week my big episode 1
video will post after the first episode
airs Sunday
night those episode videos will go up
Sunday nights then I'll do trailer
videos the next morning I'll do Q&A
videos and then Theory videos and bonus
videos during the week if you have any
special requests for ongoing videos
during the season just let me know in
the comments below
congratulations Paul even you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my breakdown
of all the early reviews reactions and
reports from the premiere a couple days
ago Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
and click here for all my Game of
Thrones Season 8 trailer and promo
videos thank you so much for watching
we're almost there just one week to go
everybody
you